trente et une pour toi clèves sa date de
l'époque que tu étais un poisson clown
et moi une petite sirène et on se
retrouvait dans des eaux souterraines
voilà c'était amer draguer par texto et
c'était toute une métaphore c'était très
drôle et personne ne sait à quel point
tu es très romantique
voilà je voulais partager ça ce soir et
je te souhaite bon courage et de force à
brune pourquoi évidemment votre
excitation et moi je trouve que cette
émission va beaucoup trop loin
déjà inscrit parce que là on rentre dans
des doses vraiment très privé et je
remercie déjà une histoire avec la suite
à une histoire de ma vie d'avant a été
très loin avec camille on a parlé oui
j'ai dragué cette fille par textos
pendant et ce qui s'est passé quelque
chose
cette femme je lui ai dit j'ai dragué
ceçi avec beaucoup de respect dont au
moins six pendant longtemps que je
faisais armato tu es une sirène ce
qu'elle chante
[Rires]
et ben moi je suis un poisson-clown toi
tu es petite sirène
ça a duré qu à ça pas mal de temps il se
trouve qu il ne s'est rien passé pendant
un moment et il se trouve qu'on s'est
retrouvé quelques années à ce coup et
que à pécho la petite soit on adore
cette super chanteuse et d'ailleurs elle
a souvent chanté et toi mais c'était pas
moi